hello welcome to see your egg honey
that's a new opponent and I hope it
doesn't play the Roku's and because i
have not yet fix this that game I lost
her one before I really wonder why why
was that so terrible okay so let's see
him in Han is this Egypt yep yeah some
kind of semi Slav got very normal
development okay 8 yeah I know a six now
be six I had almost the same position
against anti-drone no against them was
that a car by have a car by in the house
so maybe I can just centralized a little
bit him and see what he's doing
preparing for in the long run with the
bishop being somewhat weird on d6 it's
always in that pin here by the bishop on
each floor just have to be with if
always remove that quite often can lead
to mass exchanges and then nothing much
happening Quincy 7 is that a good place
for your queen
are you sure k is going back Bishop d3
maybe I'm the pin now is not existing
anymore on that night so maybe I can
trade this Bishop
yeah c-5m it white should should somehow
have a little something because of the
better development but doesn't really
strike me as being that great iam don't
have any anything particularly
convincing I'm trying to be be quicker
in this game it takes before I wonder
how I recapture maybe pawn takes
actually
ctx I don't know night cheeks okay mmm
that I did not expect I mean not in
there not not in the know at all day if
I take on c5 you will take with the beep
on I can also just take here
I thought Knight takes Knight takes
Bishop takes Queen a three they have
before ideas maybe 85 to stop any but
then Bishop b5 comes no that's not good
ok I think here I have to check with the
night to have that square on c6 as an
idea he takes seems harmless ok well he
doesn't threaten on g2 i have f 3 which
traps the whole thing so maybe rooks III
or something hmm stumbles into night c5
ok maybe he can take g 2 by the way f3
bishop h3 look somewhat sick but might
be might be possible Queen d6 though
maybe 26 for Roxy 7i 95b 495 before look
28 yeah okay hmm 25 thats gets
complicated but I've got some extra time
that's good not easy for black now
why is he going whoopsie ATM night f5 is
also an idea that I should not forget
about mm-hmm 9f 5sg 5s is hanging by
rook and queen Oh is really taking a
long time man well okay so before Luke
the 825 f6 queen age five is the line
that I looked at I'm a became known can
also go to c7 and also quite possible
Quincy 727
Bishop g2 f3 yeah that's not bad at all
okay hmm interesting if I take and go
look C 7 a-6 k 95 maybe okay maybe do
this probably going to win on time him I
defended that well at least I didn't see
anything okay I'd see that he does not
go all night if I and this is got b5
it's still okay for him position wise at
least black forfeits on time yeah yeah
it was always a little bit of pressure
but defended that well I guess txt
stinks here and now well between the six
looked interesting I spent almost so a
minute there I thought nights if I've
looked almost forced couldn't really I
didn't see anything else 825 97.7 and
night at 6a defended that very well you
just took took too much time it's kind
of like I'm playing
playing basically ok but then losing on
time kill relate the end still ok for
him huh i'm still ok somewhat yeah he
printed very well defending this food
slightly uncomfortable position but he
just took too much time ok well thanks
for watching